[Applaudissements]
le message est clair si joe biden a pris
tout son temps pour sélectionner sa
colistière à peine nommé kamal un ace
elle doit se mettre au travail
immédiatement
[Musique]
une vidéo promotionnelle pour la
campagne et puis une première apparition
publique aux tacots l'occasion pour le
candidat démocrate de justifier son
choix au soir shitov elle est brillant
elle est solide expérimentée c'est une
battante dit il prête à défendre la
classe moyenne dresse le portrait d'une
amérique en crise sous d'un autre chose
un pays à reconstruire et surtout face
aux inégalités raciales au racisme
systémique une nation dit il qui doit
retrouver son âme des thèmes chers au
coeur de cammalleri avec ses origines
indiennes et jamaïcaines elle représente
un visage de l'amérique souvent ignorée
à washington un électorat crucial pour
les démocrates
kamala harris parle d'un moment pivot de
l'histoire américaine
tout ce qui compte à nos yeux est
menacée dit elle l'économie la santé nos
enfants et alors que le pays demande un
leader fort précise-t-elle notre
président ne pense qu'à lui-même
interpellé dans notre chance c'est clair
cherche encore le meilleur angle
d'attaqué contre cette nouvelle
adversaires she wants a wife traque
n'offre à qui elle veut hausser les
taxes et les contres l'énergie fossile
she wants nul face au fioul au faso
h il tente de la présenter comme une
grossiste radicale mais le message sonne
faux quelques années à peine avant de
devenir président d'un autre homme avait
soutenu financièrement la campagne de
kamala harris en californie